in the last video we showed that the
laplace transform
of f
prime
of t
is equal to
s times the laplace transform
of our function f
minus f of zero
now what we're going to do here is
actually use this property that we
showed is true and use it to fill in
some more of the entries in our in our
laplace transform table that you'll
probably have to memorize
sooner or later if you use laplace
transforms a lot but we already learned
that the laplace transform
we know that the laplace transform
of this of sine
of a t
is equal and we did a very hairy
integration by parts problems to show
that that is equal to
a
over s squared
plus a squared
so let's use this let's use these two
things we know to figure out what the
laplace transform
of
cosine of a t is so the laplace
transform
the laplace transform of cosine
of a t
is equal to what
well if we assign assume that the
laplace transform of cosine of a t
is the derivative of some function what
what is it the derivative of right if i
were to let me do it on the side
if
f prime of t
is equal to cosine
of a t
what is a potential f of t
what is a potential f of t
well it's the antiderivative and we
could just forget about the constant
because we just have to know a and f of
t for which this is true
so what's the anti-derivative cosine of
what's 1 over a
it's 1 over a
sine of a t
right
so
if this is if this is f prime of t
then that is equal to s times that's
equal to s times
the laplace transform
of its
of its antiderivative
or 1 over a
sine
of a t
minus
the antiderivative evaluated at 0 minus
1 over a sine of well a times 0 is 0.
well sine of 0 is 0 so this whole term
goes away
so this is equal to well this is a
constant right this one over a and we
showed that the laplace transform is a
linear operator so we can take it out so
this is equal to
s
over a times the laplace transform
of sine
of a t
and that is equal to s over a times
a over s squared plus a squared and the
a's cancel out and that was
much simpler than the integration by
parts we had to do to figure this out so
then we get that the laplace transform
the laplace transform of cosine of a t
is equal to
s over s squared plus a squared and in
three minutes we filled in another table
in our laplace transform table and this
is and now we have you know the two most
important trig functions let's keep
going we haven't really done much much
with polynomials we know a couple of
things we know that the whoops
we know that the laplace transform
we did this already we know that the
laplace transform of one is equal to
one over s so let's see if we could use
this
and the fact that the laplace transform
of f prime
is equal to s times the laplace
transform
of f
minus
f of
zero
or another way let's let's rewrite let's
rearrange this like if we know f how can
we figure out a laplace transforms in
terms of f prime and f of zero so let's
let's just rearrange this equation so we
get the laplace transform
of f prime i could write of t but
that gets monotonous plus
f of 0
is equal to s times the laplace
transform
of f
divide both sides by s let me put the
the laplace transform of f and i'm also
going to switch the sides so i get the
laplace transform
my l's are getting funky the laplace
transform of f
is equal to
one over s
i'm just dividing both sides by s so one
over s times this
times the laplace transform
of my derivative
plus my function evaluated at 0.
and let's see if we can use this to
figure out this and this to figure out
some some more useful laplace transforms
well what is the laplace transform
of
the laplace transform what is the
laplace transform of
f of t is equal to t
laplace transform of f of t is equal to
t
well just let's use this property this
is going to be equal to
1 over s
times the laplace transform of the
derivative well what's the derivative of
t the derivative of t is 1. so it's the
laplace transform of 1.
minus f of zero when t equals zero this
becomes zero minus zero
so the laplace transform
of t
is equal to one over s times the laplace
transform of one well that's just one
over so it's one over s squared
minus zero
interesting laplace transform of one is
one over s laplace transform of
t
is one over s squared let's figure out
what the laplace transform of t squared
is and i'll do this one in green
and maybe we'll see a pattern emerge
the laplace transform of t squared
well it equals one over s
times the laplace transform of of its
derivative so what's the laplace tran
what's this derivative
times the laplace transform of
2t
plus
this evaluated zero well that's just
zero
so this is equal to well we could just
take this constant out this is equal to
two
over s
times the laplace transform
of t
well what does that equal
that is equal to we just solved it one
over s squared so it's two over s times
one over s squared so it's equal to
two over s to the third
two over s
to the third
fascinating well let me ask you
let me ask you a a well let me just do t
to the third and i think then you'll see
you'll see the pattern
the pattern will emerge
the laplace transform
and i i this is actually kind of fun i i
recommend you do it it's it's somehow
satisfying it's much more satisfying
than integration by parts so laplace
transform of t to the third is one over
s
times the laplace transform of its
derivative which is three
t squared
which is take the constant out because
the linear operator three over s times
the laplace transform
of t
squared
so it equals what what's the plus
transform of t square is 2 over s the
third
so this equals 3 times 2 over what s
to the fourth and you could put a t over
n here and use an inductive argument to
figure out a general formula and that
general formula is and i think you see
the pattern here whatever my exponent is
the laplace transform has an s in the
denominator with one larger exponent and
then the numerator is the factorial of
my exponent so in general
and this is one more entry in our
laplace transform table
the laplace transform
of t
to the nth power
is equal to
n factorial
over
s
to the n
plus one
s
to the n plus one
that's a parenthesis i guess i didn't
have to write those parentheses it just
confuses it but anyway this sometimes
looks like a fairly you know when you
see this in a laplace transform table it
seems intimidating oh boy i have n's and
i have n factorials and all that but
it's just saying with this pattern we
showed whatever you know t to the third
increase it by one so s to the fourth
put in the denominator and take 3
factorial on the numerator which is 6
right
and that's all it is so we have
in using the property the derivative
property of laplace transform we figured
out the laplace transform of
of cosine of a t
and the laplace transform of any well
really any polynomial right because the
linear operator so now we can you know
we know t to the nth power t to the
whatever power and multiply it by
constant so we know the basic trig
functions we know the exponential
function and we know
we know
how to take the laplace transform of
polynomials
see you in the next video